Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Imagina si pudieses conectar
tu cerebro a una máquina
que te brindase el máximo placer
el resto de tu vida.
Si tuvieses la oportunidad de
hacer realidad ese tipo de vida
¿te apuntarías?
Esa es la pregunta del
filósofo Robert Nozick
y su experimento mental que llamaba
"La máquina de las experiencias".
El experimento nos pide
pensar en un mundo
en donde los científicos desarrollaron
una máquina que simula la vida real
y asegura experiencias placenteras
en las que no hay dolor.
¿El único problema?
Tendrías que dejar atrás la realidad,
pero sin casi notar la diferencia.
Las experiencias serán
indistinguibles de la realidad.
Los altibajos naturales de la vida
serán reemplazados
por una secuencia infinita
de momentos positivos.
Suena muy bien, ¿verdad?
Puede parecer una oferta tentadora,
pero puede que no sea tan buena.
De hecho, el experimento se creó
para refutar una idea filosófica
llamada hedonismo.
Según los hedonistas,
maximizar el placer es lo
más importante en la vida
porque el placer es el bien más grande
que la vida tiene para ofrecer.
Para los hedonistas, la mejor opción que
cualquiera podría elegir para sí mismo
es la que le trae
el máximo placer posible
sin producir dolor.
El placer sin fin más cero dolor
es igual al máximo placer,
o en otras palabras,
el mismo escenario que ofrece
"La máquina de las experiencias".
Así que si el hedonismo
es tu orientación filosófica,
conectarte a la máquina
sería la opción obvia.
Pero ¿y si la vida no se resume
a solo el placer?
Es lo que Nozick cree
que estaba demostrando
con su experimento mental
"La máquina de las experiencias".
Aunque la máquina
promete máximo disfrute,
él decidió no conectarse,
lo mismo que otros al
presentarse la propuesta.
Pero, ¿qué nos puede disuadir para
elegir un futuro lleno de placer?
Imagina la siguiente situación:
Betsy y Xander están comprometidos
en una relación amorosa.
Betsy está totalmente enamorada
y nunca se sintió tan feliz.
Pero sin que Betsy lo sepa,
Xander ha estado involucrado
sentimentalmente con su hermana Angélica
a través de las cartas de amor
y reuniones secretas durante la relación.
Si Betsy se entera,
esto terminaría su relación
con Xander y Angélica
y la experiencia sería tan traumática
que tal vez no volvería a amar de nuevo.
Ya que Betsy es feliz sin saber
de las infidelidades de Xander,
los hedonistas dirían
que es mejor no saberlo
y, a cambio, mantener
su alto nivel de placer.
Mientras Betsy
no descubre la traición,
su vida seguramente seguirá
tan feliz como ahora.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el valor
de que Betsy sepa la verdad?
Imagina que tú eres Betsy.
¿Prefieres saber la verdad?
Si la respuesta es sí,
estás eligiendo algo que reduce
drásticamente los valores de placer.
Por lo cual, tal vez crees
que hay cosas en la vida
que tienen un valor intrínseco
más alto que la mera satisfacción.
La verdad, el conocimiento, una relación
auténtica con otros seres humanos;
todas estas son cosas que
pueden incluirse en esa lista.
Sin saber nunca la verdad,
Betsy está básicamente viviendo dentro
de su propia máquina de las experiencias
en un mundo de felicidad que no tiene
ninguna base en la realidad.
Este triángulo amoroso
es un ejemplo extremo,
pero refleja muchas de las
decisiones que tomamos a diario.
Así que sea tomes una decisión
por Betsy o para ti mismo,
¿por qué crees que la realidad
se debe tener en cuenta?
¿Hay un valor intrínseco
en las experiencias reales,
sean placenteras o dolorosas?
¿Tú mismo das más valor
a los placeres y dolores de la vida real?
El experimento de Nozick puede que
no ofrezca todas las respuestas,
pero nos obliga a reflexionar sobre
la vida real que, aunque imperfecta,
tiene un valor intrínseco más allá
del estado de placer infinito.